welcome back to las vegas now as we
approach summer we want to make sure we
feel
and look our best and that we show our
natural glow from the inside out
blue point medical spa can help all
thanks to their diamond glow facial
check it out
diamond glow is a medical grade skin
treatment
that exfoliates extracts and infuses
serums deep into the skin
the diamond glow is good for all skin
types dry skin
acneic skin hyperpigmentation it's
really customizable
if you look to your right you'll see the
treatment the serum is going
into the diamond tip head during the
diamond glow
treatment we're exfoliating your skin
that top layer
of just dead skin that just sits there
and builds up over time
and then we're cleaning out your pores
so they're going to be squeaky clean
after
and then we're going to infuse serums
serums and
vitamins deep into the skin this will
help with your hydration
this will also um calm your skin
as well so it's great for
treatments for like say you're like your
mom she wants to come in for like
mother's day
this treatment is good for both male and
female clients
this is really good to do a series of
two to four
of these treatments about four to six
weeks apart from one another
for optimal results it's about 45
minutes
from start to finish and again
afterwards there's no down time you can
go about your day another nice thing
about these treatments they tend to last
longer than a traditional facial
you'll notice in the next day or two
that your skin actually looks
even better even after the first day
you've had the treatment
with this treatment it's instant results
your skin afterwards is going to be
hydrated more
firm and glowing it's really good to do
right before an event
your skin will be exfoliated hydrated
and just looking
so good and as i'm treating is taking
off the dead skin
is infusing the hydration into the skin
and when
we are finished we'll be able to see all
of the dead skin that we've taken off
today everything goes into we call it a
waste jar
and it'll go into the jar and we can
take a look and see everything that came
out of your skin
we'll see just the dirt and the oil and
impurities that were just trapped in
your pores the diamond glow treatment
is not just for your face you can do it
anywhere on your body
you can do your back your chest your
arms
it's going to always exfoliate that
outer layer and just get that fresh skin
to the surface
so with things opening up we're going to
be outdoors more we're going to be
showing our skin more it's time to get
your skin ready right now the diamond
glow special runs through the end of may
it's 165 normally but right now it's
140.
blue point medical spa is located at
3320
north buffalo drive suite 103. call them
at 702-307-3330 and don't miss
out on their special offer 15 off
diamond glow treatment through the end
of may
visit bluepointmedicalspa.com for
additional specials
and las vegas now we'll be right back